the Joe Rogan experience again with the
looming litigation I do get a little bit
sort of tongue shy because this is just
gonna be a poppy suit again man this
kind of freaks me out I really what you
know it's the same premise of writing a
book it's like great write a book but
it's like I can't do anything with it
because I'll be sued I'll be suing see
it's a virtual guarantee now the the the
bright side is it seems to me like
Marineland is not going to be around for
terribly long a terribly long time once
they're dissolved oh you bet your ass I
got lots to talk about I mean I would
love if I could speak of everything
without having to sort of watch you know
I really do have to keep from saying a
lot of stuff not on account of it being
illegal but just on account to the fact
that it will it'll virtually guarantee
me additional hostilities and you know
yeah I completely understand I do look
forward to that day where I'm sort of
free and unencumbered and just can just
be [ __ ] me again you know yeah well
if you're in that business right now you
got to be looking at the future going we
got to get out we got to get out before
they take us out that's precisely what's
happening so the speculation is marine
lands lawyer is now the sole controlling
mind and he that's precisely what his
job is to transition this from we know
that they've sold property they sold the
golf course they sold the campground we
know now that they're there I'll say
I'll use the word selling it might not
be the right term because marine land
claims there'll be no financial
exchanges but you know that that's yet
to be seen
yeah the writing's on the wall they're
gonna be gone I don't think the wife has
any interest what I mean she's she's
pushing 70 something it's probably
doesn't want to be a part of this she's
never really had a heavy hand in it I
mean she had her she had she sort of
took care of the cash business aspect of
it she's sort of she had her role in it
but it wasn't like a management position
making decisions on animals health
importing exporting things like this
like it's just beyond her so what we've
been told is that's marine lands owner
in his final days there's a wish list
this is what happens to the park this is
what happens with this this is what
happens with this and you
can bet your ass that there's something
about a walrus and there's something
about me in there what it is at least
that I know of
right now is obviously hostilities till
the end I think that what's happening is
the lawyer is fulfilling John holders
wishes with me I think it's I think it's
in the books that he can't just end this
thing or I don't know it's it's good
time I know the guys dead let it go
folks a lawyer doesn't like me okay we
on the same you're talking a lot of [ __ ]
bro you know what he actually said
camera told him to go [ __ ] himself or
whatever he said that's gonna be in
court document I didn't say that I said
that to Senator that's okay will it be
in court documents
oh he's watching he's listening I mean I
sort of half hope that he Sue's you joy
to say that my [ __ ] I don't wish that on
my best of friends but man would that be
something it's not gonna happen
but [ __ ] do you know it's not gonna
happen no you're just talking [ __ ] you
should put it out there mouth yeah it's
not gonna juju we talked about this last
time
dude I think that what they do in terms
of that business for their own sake they
should stop for everyone that's
profiting off that you've got to find an
exit strategy and I don't just mean
Marineland I mean anyone who understands
my language that's that's hearing my
words you should stop this is not the
future this is you can't do that anymore
this is going this is going to look
horrible
just a few years from now we're people
who've seen blackfish people who do
understand what those things are the
more we find out about dolphins and
orcas the more we understand them it's
gonna be more and more it's not like oh
wait a minute we just did some tests we
found they're like crabs bro they're
dumb as [ __ ] like you just eat them
that's not gonna happen man we're more
and more impressed with them the more we
study them I am more than happy to
negotiate with marine land that rather
than signing any type of
non-disparagement because I don't want
my speech virtually locked in a you know
in a legal document
I'm a forgiving person I don't need i'm
only responding in kind to their
hostilities they come at me with war I
bring it back I don't want to I have to
yeah I take it right back up to where
they bring it then they do this I got to
do this then they do this I'm like what
he [ __ ] thinking saying if they would
just just dial it back I can be a happy
smiley not chirping Marineland guy I
don't have to be I don't have to do that
I've done what I've had to to be where I
am the man who was who created this
scenario is gone we don't need the
hostilities anymore so what is the
lawyers motives exactly I don't know but
I can assure you now that they've
blacked out the fence they're doing
everything they can to suppress our
information they've bought up all the
billboards in all the available
billboards in Niagara Falls so that
they've got Marineland signs because we
have put out like as activists activists
have put up billboards one of which was
like right at the entrance to Marineland
last year is a thing of beauty so they
you know they bought all these things up
they really don't want bad PR right now
my guess is trying to get rid of the
animals mitigate the PR losses because
it's already at the sound foundation of
it of bad PR and sell the property get
rid of it all and I think you know
they're trying to fast-track and
accreditation so that they can
facilitate animal movements and whatnot
my greatest weapon right now
unfortunately is that I can assure them
a great deal of of financial risk I have
and I certainly can and am right now
they need to take that into
consideration when you consider the
price of a walrus and let's just use the
number a hundred thousand which is a
grossly inflated number for a walrus and
let's say marine land were to say
hypothetically well why would we give
you $100,000 asset when it's gonna cost
us less than that just to finish this
litigation and we'll owe you 25k at the
end of some [ __ ] why would we do it
doesn't make sense and I say to them
it's because I'm gonna make that walrus
cost you tens of millions consider that
lose the hostilities I'll make you guys
heroes we can do that too the narrow
this narrative doesn't have to continue
the narrative of war can end with with
the dead owner it could have ended but
well they're all invested in it and one
of the things about
suits it's like people when they get it
started there's a game going on you're
trying to win you're trying to win
trying to get the other side to cave I
mean this is a lot of what this is all
and obviously you've taken this very
personally and this is all part of you
now can I explain something really
messed up yeah I now because we're
coming to an end the law that I've been
advocating for is going to pass this
lawsuit is going to end the animals will
that I mean we're gonna find out what's
gonna happen to them in in the in the
near future we already know it's what's
becoming of some I don't know what it's
gonna be like to live without a lawsuit
once the prospect is not a nice bro
you're gonna be on the beach to feed up
when the prospect came round of me not
having one anymore that's not how I saw
it it's weird I'm oddly connected
strangely addicted and married to a
[ __ ] lawsuit I get it you'll be fast
it listen we'll get you through
[Applause]